some critics are really slamming the
Republicans for adding a lot of
handwritten notes at the last second to
win over individual people who were
holding out literally handwritten notes
like this one a special tax break that
was written in for Betsy divorces
college this was written in specifically
for her college so that they could get
her support there are other last-minute
additions to the bill that I was looking
at that I think are equally suspect for
instance check this one out freeways
will have a dedicated lane for coal
powered cars that was weird yeah look at
this one immigration officers can deport
any individual found possessing
jalapenos Mitch McConnell must receive a
standing ovation every time he walks
into a Waffle House look at this Rhode
Island will now be used for storage yeah
look at this Fox is the only acceptable
news source after the Bible and the
toast that looks like Jesus
check this one out from now on
Japan shall be known as China Junior hey
check this out Papa John is officially a
founding father here's this one anyone
can refuse to make a gay cake but since
cakes in general are pretty gay all
Baker's must admit that all cakes are
gay cakes and finally check it out the
motto at the base of the Statue of
Liberty will now be changed - not so
fast amigo
[Applause]
you